the lazier you are the more successful
you can be if you give a hardworking
person a problem they give you a
hardworking solution if you give a lazy
person a problem they'll give you a lazy
man solution and a lot of times some of
the best problems in the world get
solved by deciding they're not problems
what do you mean let's say Lela says you
know babe and I don't like being called
babe I could have a huge discussion
about this it makes me feel this way it
reminds me of my mom whatever or I
decide that it's not a problem and it's
way faster to solve problems that way by
deciding they're not problems to begin
with interesting I'm a big believer in
working smarter not harder with the
massive C that you have to work
incredibly hard to get some